and when you're in those other cities in
those countries you do see a difference
you you understand what it is to be
american do you speak japanese a little
bit i still have japanese driver's
license so have it on me oh cool cool
nice i love it
it is literally like i don't know 30
years old or something 30 years old i
still keep it huh
sweet japanese driver's license yes look
at this guy yeah looking all young that
wasn't many years ago what were some of
the biggest differences you noticed that
it may be off the top of your head yeah
i remember one time something was
happening i forgot what it was it was
probably in the late 80s early 90s as
i'm gonna guess and we were talking
about burning the american flag
and one of the students asked me i said
larry why do you guys care so much when
we when you burn the american flag like
no one in japan cares you burn the
japanese fly that's why no one burns
japanese flag because we don't care
doesn't make the news nobody cares i
said because you gotta understand
something in japan you were united by so
many things
and this particularly in the 90s for
sure but even now still speak the same
language
same religion
same school system write read the same
books watch the same tv
eat the same foods they're very much
connected on a different level but when
you come to america we're not we don't
have those similarities we are linked by
our symbols
we are linked by our ideology that's how
we're linked the flag means a lot to us
because it's a symbol of what keeps us
together we don't have the same other
things japanese you don't require a flag
that's just a piece of
claw to them they know they're all too
they know they're all japanese that's
most countries not all obviously but
that's many countries countries that are
not as homogeneous or who don't have
that connection culturally
rely more on symbols
and i think that was also a part of me
to understand that idea that how
you know some symbols matter how our
president is one of the only um leaders
who is both the head of state and head
of government and that gives him so much
power and how we look in most countries
when something goes wrong
they blame the leader
right something goes wrong oh something
happened you're a bad leader we do the
opposite some went wrong leader save us
right so when 9 11 happened somebody
blamed bush they all said bush come save
us right that happened in japan that
government falls
wow
i think the the symbols thing is is very
apt very accurate because i've often
brought up why you know
i think this this country is so
important we are a
we have a variety of different ethnic
backgrounds religions and the one thing
that we all have in common is that we're
americans and that's why i really uh i
very much despise the the critical race
theorists and their ideologies that
segregate based on race want us all to
focus on races and and identities
because
you you can't really tell i mean the
issue for me is obvious and i brought it
up you know with the audience very often
but having someone decide for you what
you should be allowed to do based on
your race and then separating people i'm
like no we're all americans here and
that's that's that's the one thing we
all have that's our identity is american
because there are a lot of people who
are here or first second third
generation immigrant
their their identity is not i mean if
you're if you're the the grandchild of
immigrants
you have a very short-lived american
tradition you probably don't know too
much about the old country maybe a
little bit from your grandparents what
if you're what if it's your
great-grandparents you have american
traditions and so the one thing that
unites all of us is it's america we have
a flag we have a national anthem we have
the pledge all of those things and we
stand together for these ideas we have a
constitution unfortunately now
whether it's because of social media or
universities
there is a
growing conflict with a lot of people
who don't believe in the flag they hate
it they hate this country they think
it's evil they want to see it destroyed
and they're gaining more and more power
i think there's powerful political
elites i think they can wield this this
this
raucous faction
and that it will give them some kind of
edge but they can't control it i think
there's two parts that
kind of make that hard one of them is
fractured media
right the fractured media which i think
in general is a good thing but this is a
bad side to fractured media now we're
all watching
you know we're not all watching walter
cronkite tell us what's good we're
watching individuals tell us what we
kind of get right we're staying in those
those areas that's well that's a great
thing for choice that's a great thing
for freedom it's really for information
that there's more benefit than there is
downside to this but one downside is
that but now that becomes second
downside our politicians our system
doesn't support anybody
so what does that what i mean by that
all the problems that happen
democrats are the party of bad ideas
republicans of the party have no ideas
so no one has actually helped
i completely agree and when no one is
helped people go well who's going to
help me people have problems now in a
libertarian world
we support communities for communities
to help people that's what we should be
doing in our perfect world obviously
we're not there but we want to start to
create a world where communities help
people fall down people make mistakes
people get in trouble that's what
happens we're human beings and we want
to have a world to where the community
stuff and go okay i got you right you
come out of prison community should help
you you're an addict community should
help you right that's that's the goal
for us to be there we don't do that we
create programs what programs do is they
service you they don't help you
they service you so they keep you where
you are forever so we all have jobs but
actual actual nonprofits that are not
funded by the government
those actually help people how do you
know because they have a donor base you
don't give money to somebody let's just
show you a success story
so i'm incentivized if i'm not
government funded to give you a success
story see look i did something we helped
someone i'm incentivized to do that but
if i'm government funded i'm not i'm i'm
incentivized to check a box
i check the box i get my government
money now you might say wait a minute
there are non-profits who who are
terrible look at them most of them are
government-funded which means what does
that mean they're not actually
non-profits they're just government
agencies that are non-unionized
so the government gets non-unionized
workers that's what that actually is
second amendment
yes what about it how do you feel about
it i am the only candidate who was pro
2a in all of new york state
not even close the only one i was only
one in 2018 who actually had a plan to
end our safe act and so those you may
not know the safe act in new york state
was enacted in 2013
after sandy hook which by the way did
not happen in new york state
but it was to stop all the sandy hooks
that were happening in new york state
which was exactly
uh none
there was no problem we created a safe
act where basically what it said was you
are about a million new yorkers who
legally purchased your firearm now you
are violent felons
because if you have a firearm violation
in new york state by default it's
violent whether you do anything with
that firearm or not it may literally
plastic pieces that go on your firearm
illegal it created a black market
ammunition a black market and firearms
making law enforcement's job even harder
it made it made sure that people who
have a smaller stature can't get
accessories to be able to use firearms
well and it made sure that veterans knew
that if they got reported that they
would lose their firearms so it made
veterans with ptsd and tbi issues not
report anymore
it created a secret state police and
that now our medical personnel have to
report there's any problem this actually
happened i think it was rochester
where a guy comes in after a car
accident the nurse says oh my god how
are you feeling he goes i feel so bad i
want to die she checked boxes suicidal
state police came back to his firearms
wow yes so that kind of stuff happened
from the safe act it made it made new
yorkers feel terrible about it and many
of them have left because of it
so i was the only one in 2018 who had a
plan to actually end it new york state
is insanely anti-gun and i mean insanely
anti-gun to the point where if you take
your legally purchased firearm and you
follow every tsa guideline it is
unlocked i'm sorry it's locked up and
unloaded and you follow every tsa
guideline you bring that firearm into
new york city you are going to rikers
island this is that is going to happen
yes the most violent jail in the country
you are going there whether you are male
or a female with or without kids that's
happened more than once luke was uh i i
think i think it was lucas as long as
lukewarm change
saying that uh there are stories where
people will be traveling through new
york and it's for like maybe an
international flight or somewhere yep
they'll have a legal gun it'll be an
illegal case locked
no ammunition yep semi-dism you know
magazine removed or whatever yep
they'll check it in their legal state
and that new york city has cops waiting
knowing when you have a gun and they
wait for you to put your hand on the bag
and the moment you do they walk up and
arrest you for a legal position correct
that's accurate and in new york state
loaded has a different definition
loaded is ammunition in the vicinity of
the of the firearm what's the vicinity
mean thank you
thank you yes
yes it means i
i don't know there's a box there and a
firearm there that's loaded that's what
that means wow yes new york state's
insane we have the we have the stickers
gun laws
in the country
so what i want to make is simple laws
simple just universal transportation how
about that any place you go in new york
state anywhere no matter what the local
gun laws are doesn't matter if your
firearm is locked and unloaded you don't
go to jail
that's not crazy that is that is a law
that people could accept you don't if
you bought your farm legally it's locked
and unload and change the definition of
loaded loaded means gonna sound crazy
bullets in the gun
that's it
that's loaded bullets are in the gun
that is loaded they're not in the gun
it's unloaded just do that now that
means other counties
can have looser laws that they want to
no worries and many will right lots of
rural counters was much easier carrier
laws and i'm happy with that i wish
there were more but new york city is not
going to be
looser than that right now it's not
where new york city is it's not where
rochester is most of the cities aren't
that way so at least get to that plus
i'll do something else to get a permit
in new york state new york state is not
a shall issue state it's a may issue
state and it's i believe it's called um
it's called uh it's literally a may
issue yep but actually a no issue
correct that's accurate so i want to
change it to a shall issue if they don't
issue your permit in 90 days they have
nine day waiting period that they can
check you out do whatever they want to
do within 90 days if they don't say yes
it's yes
and if they say yes and we by the way we
have an example of this already in new
york city with the department of
buildings you have to build in new york
city or the real estate moguls will
destroy you so our department of
buildings has a rule i think it's four
months i'm not sure if you don't get
approved within four months you're
approved or whatever i've got time
period wow i want to follow the same
thing for
firearm permits 90 days and if they do
disapprove you
no worries they must give you a reason
and an appeals process why not right now
they do not have to give you a reason or
an appeals process they just go i don't
like you no that is totally legal in new
york state why 90 days though because we
already have 90 days
so i want to again familiar enough but
radical enough all right we already
right now officially we're 90 days but
what they do is they always say we don't
have enough people we don't have enough
bodies and we're
we're a may issue anyway
so they usually in certain places
they'll take two years to get a permit
we need uh there's a there's a supreme
court case coming i believe right yep um
did it already happen it did okay so
so that's that's about may issue versus
shallow shoe right the the issue we're
gonna have is the new state's gonna
fight it and they already are yeah right
but they're gonna lose
i i think
yeah i think we'll see so this is
basically um
my understanding is the suit is some
dude tried to buy a gun
and they uh denied him right they said
he needed a valid reason chris said no i
don't
now it's going now it's gone to the
supreme court correct and that's my
entire point right that should not be a
thing
if if if a county is going to deny you
they have to give you a reason why and
you have to have an appeals process let
me let me tell everybody you know look
there are a lot of people on the
establishment left side they're anti-gun
i i think they don't know anything about
guns for the most part and they there's
a lot of these people who claim to like
i served in the marines i know about
guns and it's just like then you hear
them talk and they don't right like one
guy i think was like an accountant and
he has like a twitter account where he
talks about i was a marine and they made
me lock my gun in the locker and it's
like dude you were gonna come but um
anyway here's what people don't
understand about um
maryland and new jersey as i was told
so when i was in new jersey i was like i
would i'm gonna try and buy i want to
buy a gun because um you know we had an
issue someone tried breaking in the
house and stuff
and i was told new jersey is a may issue
state but it's actually a no issue
meaning any person who applies for a
concealed carry permit because you can't
open carry at all it's got to be
concealed uh they will just deny you
it'll never happen
and then i was told but for you mr pool
oh you'll be fine they'll they will they
will get you through no problem why well
you're famous yes
the the powerful the elites correct the
famous the politicians people with money
you don't got to worry your little
pretty little face about it i was told
the same thing about maryland maryland
is very strict they say it's you know
it's it's a may issue but it's actually
a no issue
and they go oh but for you don't worry
about it so you get these politicians in
these states like in chicago this is a
big big issue everybody gets pissed off
about
politicians all have armed are they
they're armed they have armed security
they get all that stuff and then take
your right to defend yourself away
we can't have it that way well i do want
to go further i want to allow local
people to be happy locally
and a lot of times you find a lot of
people in particular in cities who
really don't are happy with only the
cops having guns
so i want to be easier on localization
meaning i want to have a a floor that is
just fair to all gun owners
and then each county can be can loosen
those as they see fit and then we move
towards looser and looser and why do we
do that because there's a cultural issue
that we have to deal with
guns aren't a logical issue
they're a cultural issue
right people to your point don't
understand guns most people in cities
look at the safe act and go well it's
been keeping us safe how do you know
well it says safe in the name i'm not
joking i've heard that more than once
like that's a thing they don't know what
it's done they don't know what's in it
they have no idea you just go well no
guns because i don't want people to be
shot many of them are good people who
just don't know what guns don't know the
value of them just go i don't like guns
because scary
so we have to get them to turn them and
show them
that there are times when a firearm is a
very good idea an example i will often
give is something like let's say you're
a um
let's say you're a small statute woman
and you have a large statute boyfriend
who has beaten you
and now he goes away to jail and now
he's out
and you'd like to have a farm to protect
yourself now i'm not saying you should
but maybe you want to again your choice
the second amendment is not a
requirement it is a right if you want to
you can if you don't want to please
don't ever use them if you don't want to
you can't
right you can't i remember the story
i'll give up often by the way i don't
own a firearm very often i support
things that don't affect me i live in
new york city
i can't own a firearm realistically
right so i don't own a firearm in new
york city um i support family law uh
reform i've never been through the
family law system so i support cannabis
i don't do any wheat so all that stuff
but my point of being a story i'll tell
you when i was a teacher there was a
woman who was a complete pacifist and i
mean total pacifist and of course
someone said well what if you were raped
right of course that question would come
up and she was very forward she goes no
no if i was raped i still would never
want to kill anybody never i want to
talk my way out of it and she goes i was
in a situation before and i did and
someone said what if he couldn't it's
her word she said i'd rather be raped
she was i'd rather deal with that trauma
than trauma of taking a life and i said
okay okay then i stepped in i said okay
but would you stop someone else from
pulling a gun and shooting a guy she
said no wow i said we're good
then we're good you live your rules i'll
live mine
right i want to shoot the guy but that's
fine that's me she doesn't i'm not here
to judge her i'm here to not enforce my
rules on her and don't let her enforce
her rules on me and we're good thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 00 pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you